tailor the lawn of the Tennessee Titans
offensive line back here on the show how
are you sir
Richard Richard glad to be back on the
show man I feel like every six months
you and I just get together for a cup of
tea and a conversation and I'm glad to
be a part of it well I have coffee here
but you know you know I'm already highly
caffeinated anyway when we have our tab
well I suppose I don't have any drinks
on me I should have some water here
SmartWater little plug there out of the
water yeah what do you think of that
block from from your guy you know I
actually didn't I didn't even see the
block so after the game to go asking me
like Oh would you think about this
ridhima I had no idea and watching the
film that's the defense event that's
Frank Zomba that's a 250 pounds
outside linebacker that is the Reid guy
yeah for Derek to have the ability to
bounce that out into Marcus I mean he's
that's two games in a row of some
physical play and I mean I think if you
watch the playoffs only there's one guy
that wants it more than Marcus besides
me well 21 3 what was it like seriously
give me the real scoop here 21 3 yeah
what's it like for you and the team but
the real scoop is well last year it was
like I think week 16 or 15 we're in a
really similar situation in the same
ways I plays against Kansas City you
know definitely wasn't a lot of cheering
going on in the locker room but it was
one of those things there was no
Remember the Titans moment where there
was a big speech or anything like that
it was just a couple of key guys saying
look we got 30 minutes left
you know this could be the end of season
or he keep it dawn that's a choice we
had the opportunity to come out with the
ball and I think it was either that
driver the next track we had 15 plays
and just just walked down the field and
it was I think from that moment our D if
I started clicking
we started clicking and really I mean
gave us a lot of confidence started this
next game that you and I both know
there's a great Michigan quarterback
that I got we got to play guess this
week I know I know that we'll get to
that in a second Taylor lawanna the rich
eyes on the Rich Eisen show from the
Tennessee Titans here so what is the
play call actually like the exact play
call of throw it up have Darrelle Revis
bat it back to me and leap for the pylon
for touchdown what's the call Taylor I
don't think I don't think you can't even
do that matter I don't even know how
that works
but uh fun facts fun story for you my
rookie year I was taking a knee and I
was with the twos and the ones are out
there
Jacob Walker literally the same exact
play did that same exact thing so as I
was giving Marcus Marcus a little bit of
a arousal about that because I was told
him I've seen it before man it's nothing
new to me
I've seen it before but what I mean what
a play that was a couple things first
off the role Revis what's your vertical
jump because that guy got in the air and
then second four marks to keep going
with the play is just unbelievable well
in terms of Revis do you think he was
turning down hits on Henry that's the
conversation that's being had and it
sure looked like that to me now that
you've watched the film as you mentioned
of that play does he turn it down
contact with Derek with Derek Henry
Taylor I don't know you know what it's
tough to me to say but I mean first I
think I should ask you that question if
you but six for 240 pounds running back
coming at you are you gonna turn down
that hit I'll tell you what Taylor cuz
again I I only watch for a living there
was a hit on Sunday because I don't know
if you saw the Sunday playoff games
coleus Campbell hit hit LeSean McCoy so
hard coming back to the play I thought
if he cuz I've interviewed him and he's
so big and I've interviewed him without
pads I wouldn't I would never get up if
I was hit and that sort of situation
honestly thought that was a big man he's
a big man to be honest with you I'm
every bit of six seven we played them
two weeks ago I was walking past him and
I'm like what like this man is literally
200 told to me they say you 6/8 he's
easily 6 nice that's a big big man well
I know the AFC South is standing in the
way of what everybody assumes was gonna
happen anyway which is New England in
Pittsburgh you know pound a table here
Taylor yeah on the table for you thank
ya I think there's a lot of people I
think every single person in the world
is probably counting us out in this one
and you know the the Patriots have
consistently gone to Super Bowl
consistently go to the AFC champions
that consistently have won Super Bowls
with the coaching staff to have their
which quarterback to have their so I
mean I'm not mad at them but to be
honest you know there's that old cliche
line
any given Sunday I'm just gonna flip
that call and in any given Saturday and
we you know have a huge opportunity here
to make a huge statement we have a lot
of talent on this team and I'll be the
first one to admit that we underachieve
this year but you know we got into the
dance and that's all that really matters
so going forward I mean going into
Foxborough what an awesome opportunity
what a cool cool opportunity this is
gonna be and I hope you know this team
takes it as seriously as I'm going to
and we're gonna go in there we're gonna
get everything we got well and in terms
of that Taylor you know you're hearing
about the infighting I guess that's
supposedly going on in New England is
that been a topic of conversation in
your locker room whatsoever I don't okay
I might I might you know break some PC
rules here but I'm gonna give my opinion
on this whole thing because I feel like
the Patriots for so long have been so
great with the ownership the coaching
staff the quarterback everybody's gone
along so well and I'm I'm gonna sit here
and say this is media BS I really I
really think that I think this is people
watching you know kind of like the
perfect storm of individuals together on
this debt on this dynasty and people
want to throw a wrench in it I just
don't I'm not biting that there's
actually some turmoil going on over
there who knows I might be totally wrong
I might be hundred percent right but uh
I don't think there's a lot much going
on there's people say there is and then
what about your locker room so much for
the conversations your coaches job was
on a line down 18 in Kansas City that
you saved as gig is that a true story do
you think you know I don't know I think
you know I was actually just listening
to you the sports or the local sports
radio here and I guess he Michael
himself says something about that and
it's press star but that's a game that
his job was in jeopardy to be totally
honest I as in sensitive this might
sound I wasn't let's I didn't care I
wasn't my focus my focus was playing
against Kansas City to win that game
you know that's it's kind of the job
obviously um coach Milwaukee's been here
for two years and he's he's done a good
job I mean if you think my rookie year
we were two and 14 be here for that we
were three and thirteen even here for
for two years and we've had winning
seasons so I don't know how much truth
or
to that but I do know that he's
definitely be our coach next year after
Amy came out with a statement saying
that that's gonna be the case I I do my
best to not I hear you always hear the
information I watched you on NFL Network
but I'm a big fan I see you guys talking
and razzing it up and it's great I just
don't I don't ever want to put too much
opinion in it I really want to focus on
what my job is on Sunday or Saturday or
whatever it is we're playing all right
well get ready for no one to give you a
chance Taylor you know that right
seriously and that's not razzing you
that's not I mean and this is also look
and I always find it kind of you know
players and coaches and organizations
use the us against the world mentality
to their to their advantage but I truly
believe this is going to be the case for
you this week for real I'm not saying
it's done no of course not I mean you're
you're as you mentioned you've got some
great players in your locker room we've
seen we've seen on guys that are are
teams that aren't expected to win to win
now I'm not saying I'm out one of those
types in the media saying you have no
shot of course not that's ridiculous of
course you have a shot but I don't think
anybody's gonna give you much of a shot
Taylor this time how do you I appreciate
that I appreciate the small leverage I
really do that's $1 you to know that I
have you in my corner it's always been
you know what man honestly like I the
only people that matter are the people
in the locker room though the ones that
are playing the game the ones that are
coaching the game it's because you know
I mean I've never been and it's crazy to
think in the NFL to say this because a
lot of people play the game for money or
they play there for the game for
different reasons and even going back as
far as high school I've been in a locker
room but these guys care about each
other as much as they do in this room so
it's you know this team definitely plays
for the guys next to them and I think
you know I would bet on us I really
would
so last one for you Taylor because I
know you you like to have fun and you're
really good at dead panning can you do
this for me this week at one point let's
pretend I'm not as smart as you think I
am what is that oh you just you are
absolutely you can you can say stuff
with a straight face when you're joking
no one can tell the difference okay so
here's the deal
it's what I want you to do here okay
when you get your first media
availability this week and they're all
around you with microphones or something
like that you say look all I'm gonna say
is this to start off this is a big
opportunity this week for you know us to
go up to New England and a Michigan
legend showing up with so much on the
line and so much at stake and one of the
all-time greats at the University of
Michigan coming up with a big game and
showing of the world exactly once again
how good he is but enough about me
what's your first question all right
I'll tell you what yeah I don't know if
you just read that from a piece of paper
I did what Raza Bravo
I didn't I'm not a I'm not that good at
it I need you or one of the Chris's or
been the muse that one of the guys over
there get it get that in writing for me
okay and it's my way whether it's
Instagram DM you got or even if it's
public I'm praying that thing out and
that will be my first date all right all
right Taylor we're gonna tweet that to
you right now from okay I need every
word verbatim and I'm going to read it
out loud to all of them and then we'll
start with the President and just say
just open it up okay now what now what
do you want to ask workshopping now
we're now we're spitballing and making
it better that's out there you know
we're bring ball I cannot wait to see
you drop that Taylor it's gonna be
awesome it's gonna be gonna be should I
give you guys and our viewers and
listeners will know we'll all be in on
it at Taylor LaJuan 77 between met at
Taylor LaJuan 7 let's do it right now
right now good luck to you Taylor we'll
chat down a lot okay all right guys when
their first career playoff win of the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience